Uh,
today we are going to be looking
at some VI uplifting writing,
an Edgar Allen Poe syndicate, red
death, illimitable dominion over.
Wow,
that's depressing.
Let's tone it down a bit on some fun on
bidding on I ponder the weekend weary
over many acquainting. Curious
volume move, forgotten on.
I nodded,
nearly napping.
Suddenly there came a tapping
as if someone gently rapping,
rapping it in my chamber
door to some visitor.
I muttered tapping at my chamber
door only this and nothing.
So the ominous mood set for one of
the most famous poems ever written,
coming from a generation of
horror stories like Stephen King.
It is very interesting to look back
at someone like Edgar Allen Poe,
who's riding while much more
subtle than we are used to.
It's still capable of sending
chills down your spine.
I'm going to first look at the structure
of the Raven as it is a very carefully
organized poem.
The rhyme scheme scene in the first
stanza is repeated throughout the poem as
well as the internal rhyme scheme.
That is the rhymes within the same line.
It feels impossible not to be
swept off by the hypnotic rhythm,
which like a drum beat slowly built in
speed and intensity until it reaches a
fever pitch where you can imagine this
speaker yelling at the top of his lungs,
Podo, something very interesting on
the second, fourth and fifth lungs.
Each line ending with the rhyme or is
one syllable shorter than the other two
and we can clearly see the final
line is much shorter than the rest.
The result is that when the raven enters
and utters the ominous word, never more,
it hangs in the reader's mind emphasizing
and exaggerating how this word
repeatedly spoken by the Raven, slowly
burrows its way into the speaker's mind,
driving him to the brink of insanity.
What starts out as a story of a talking
raven quickly spirals into a story of a
man descending into his own personal hell.
I told you this would be cheerful,
so not much is happening at the start
just to man sitting alone reading old
books.
We find out the room is filled with Purple
Silk Curtains and velvet line chairs
in a library of old sophisticated books.
It is the creepy house in every ghost
story and it seems like the perfect place
for someone to sit and brood
distinctly.
I remember it was in the bleak Duesenberg
and it's separate dying ember Reuters
ghost upon the floor eagerly.
I wish the moral Vinnie had I
sought to borrow from my books.
So Cecil sorrow,
sorrow for the [inaudible],
for the Rem Radian meeting,
the angel's name,
nameless here for ever more.
So we find out the man is trying to bury
his sorrow due to his loss of a love.
A woman named Lenore. We don't know
who she is or what happened to her.
All we know is that this
man is desperately trying to
relieve the pain of losing
her and we know the best way to get
over a girl is to brood and get all my
chemical romance about it.
He starts to have hallucinations
about her perfume filling the room and
longingly remembers her ass print on
the velvet cushions. Little weird,
but we all take heartbreak
a little differently.
I'm the silicon said,
uncertain rustling of each purple curtain
thrilled me fill me with fantastic
terros.
Never felt before.
Most of us probably know the feeling of
watching a horror movie and having every
creak of the house set.
Our nerves are on edge.
That seems to be what is
happening to our speaker here.
Then there's a rapping at the door.
This could represent a great many things.
First off, it is the unknown is
the introduction of the stranger.
The Stranger is not a person,
but rather a category of experience.
It is the introduction of
anomaly and uncertainty,
which shakes up the status
quo. The stranger fills us
with both hope and dread.
He can inspire us, shower us
with gifts, or he can kill us.
In this case,
the tapping at the door appears as a
disruption of the serene state within this
man's comfortable chamber.
Presently, my soul grows stronger,
hesitating then no longer
so finally built up the
courage to open the door,
only to find darkness and nothing back
the chamber turning all my
soul within the burning sooner.
Ghana hood at tapping
somewhat louder than before.
Soon he realizes the tapping is coming
from the window and he tries to comfort
himself,
does the wind and nothing more open.
Here I flung the shutter when with many
a flirt and flutter in the step to state
the Raven of the saint need days of Yore,
not the least of basins made he
let a minute stop to a statey,
but with mean of Lord or lady
perched above my chamber door,
perched upon the bust of partners just
above my chamber door pitched and sat and
nothing more.
And what do you do when a
bird flies into your house?
Obviously you start talking to it.
If you're a crazy person
though the Crespi shown
and shaven though I said,
I sure know craven gas,
the grim and ancient raven
wandering from the nightly shore.
Tell me what the law,
the name is on the nights
Plutonian shore quote,
the Raven Nevermore.
It is clear.
This is no ordinary bird.
He calls it a stately raven of the days
of Yore and he's clearly approaching it
with awe and respect, as you probably
know from reading Norse mythology. Okay,
who are we kidding? As you probably know
from the movie anchorman, the Norse God.
Odin has two companion Raven's named
Hugans and Muninn roughly translated to
thought and memory whom Odin gave the
power of speech just as Hugans and Muninn
pry beneath the surface of the world in
order to bring hidden truth to Oden's
ears.
So to does our speaker pry into the
hidden knowledge he believes the Raven to
possess the Raven has purchased
self atop the bust of palace.
Another name for the Greek Goddess Athena,
most commonly known as the goddess of
even more connection to the Raven as a
source of knowledge and insight.
And there was another
mythological reference when
he says the night's Plutonian
shore Pluto,
who you'll probably know better as
Haiti's was god of the underworld.
A Raven often depicts it,
a top skeletons or scavenging a field
of human corpses seems exactly like the
kind of beast that would
occupy our nightmares.
It also perfectly sets the mood for this
dark and brooding pool of a man alone
in his room or depending on how you look
at it alone in his mind with nothing to
occupy him but his own disturbing
thoughts and memories. Now,
the communication between the
man and the refund continues.
The question starts simple.
He first asked the ravens name.
He then asks if on the morrow he will
leave me as my hopes have flown before.
Then the bird said never more.
Then upon the velvet seeking,
I took myself to linking fancy
on the fancy thinking, what?
This ominous bird of yours,
what this grim on game day gasoline
gone an ominous burden of your meant and
cooking and nevermind.
He keeps posing more and more
serious questions to the Raven.
The main already knows the
answer to each question.
It's still he holds on hope that the
raven will tell him something different,
but soon as he digs deeper,
the answers we'll begin to peck
and pry on comfortably at his mind.
He asks if the thing he most
longs for to see his loss,
Lynn nor will ever come to be
quote the Raven nevermore
profit I thing of evil profits to live
Berto would devil a temptress sandal
weather tempest tossed Thedo shore
Deslie jet all on daunted Nanda.
This desert land and chanted on this home
by a horror haunted telling me truly I
implore is there is the
bomb and kill had tell me,
tell me.
I implored.
Is there bombing Giliad is just a fancy
pants way of asking if you will ever
find relief from his sorrow.
Quote the Raven nevermore
be that word I sign of partying.
Brutal feeding.
Nice shrieked upstarting get the back
into the tempest and the knights Plutonian
shore leave. No black plume as
a token of that lied I sold,
have spoken. Lead my loneliness
unbroken. Quit the buster above my door.
Take ty beak from out my heart and
take life form and what my door caught.
The never mom,
the speaker is blaming all his pain and
sorrow on the appearance of the Raven
and shrieks for it to go. But the
Raven refused. It is the old adage,
wherever you go,
there you are.
The Raven now appears to be
a dark fragment within the
man's soul and something
he's completely incapable of escape.
No matter how hard we
tried to banish them,
the ravens have our own thoughts and
memories will forever remain is our
constant companions.
And the Raven never flooding.
Still is sitting,
still is sitting on the pallet bust of
palace just above my chamber door and his
eyes have all the seeming of demons that
is dreaming and the lamp light oil in
streaming throws his shadow on the floor.
And my soul amount,
that shadow that lies floating
on the floor shall be lifted.
Never.